how are you using your mind today to
either make yourself feel great or not i
posted on instagram this morning i said
listen your destiny is ultimately
controlled due by a decision you already
made this morning everyone watching this
already made a decision this morning
this morning they made it a
life-changing huge decision this morning
and that is either
i'm going to get up
enter the world with no intention
go through the motions to hopefully get
by or survive or
i am going to get clear in this morning
about what i want what i'm going after
who i'm going to be how i'm going to
serve and whether or not i'm going to be
excellent and extraordinary
or not
and the problem is most people never
make that conscious decision
so and so i was learning early on make
the conscious decision about who you
want to be each day
stay congruent with that
and that was
you know for me a kid who's just going
through the motions all of a sudden
going oh
who do i want to be what do i want my
relationships to be like that was really
important
and then i started setting personal
challenges every month
at the beginning of each month i did
this whole thing where i holistically
evaluate my life on the first of every
month
and it's like these 10 different
categories of my life you know from
emotional to relational to financial to
um you know career mission objectives
all these things i go down that uh on
the first month just kind of holistic
viewpoint in my life and then i set a
personal challenge and a professional
challenge
and
i do that every month
every sunday i revisit my progress
every sunday for 23 years
so it's not like i'm just you know
one day ended up in a happy life it was
like that a level of self-evaluation
that most people avoid
until their birthday or new year's i do
it every sunday and every first of the
month and i don't ever miss
and i think that has helped me kind of
know what my thing is
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the habits
that can change your life
enjoy
habit number two create positive
patterns with tony robbins i'll give you
three patterns real fast so you can
check yourself out for a moment so one
pattern is of focus
do you tend to focus more on what you
have or what's missing i'm asking your
listeners right now and you what do you
tend to focus on what you have or what's
missing what i have what do you have
great when i ask this in a room usually
about 70 are focused on what's missing
most achievers are focused on what's
missing so they can go out and achieve
more right yeah nothing wrong with that
but when you stack these patterns
together it's really hard to be happy
when you're constantly focused on what's
missing there's a time notes missing so
you go to work but if you do it all the
time yeah you can be achieving a ton
like some of these billionaires and
they're still
mostly what's missing and so they're not
happy
another pattern would be
do you tend to focus on what you can
control or what you can't control for me
cam yeah and i i know that's true with
you yeah the majority of people is what
they can't control
now if you focus on what's missing all
the time and what you can't control
you're gonna be depressed i don't care
if you take prozac or zoloft or anything
else your depression is not a zoloft
deficiency it is the fact that you were
doing something in your mind that is
producing that depression and if you
constantly focus on what's missing and
what you can't control and look at a
third one do you tend to focus more on
things in the past
the present
or the future i know you do all three we
all do all three but which one for you
would you say you spend more of your
time on past present or future well my
old self would say the past and the
future
now after going to one world academy i'm
very present and present and future
yeah well there's no right or wrong that
the past
you can't do anything about it so the
more you focus there unless you're
learning something from it yeah it's
pretty much a waste the present is where
the joy is the future is how you do
business right so you anticipate so it's
the ability to do this but if you have
someone whose pattern is
focusing what's missing focus on what i
can't control focus on the past
you can give them i've seen it i've
dealt with people like that who are
suicidal i come in they got every drug
they're taking every antidepressant and
they're still depressed in fact what
i'll ask an audience is all the time how
many of you know somebody who takes into
person still depressed ninety percent of
them will raise their hand i know people
you know people i'm sure people at home
do well
why are they so depressed that they're
taking any depression because all the
depression does is numb you
but they're still focusing what's
missing they're still focused on what
they can't control they're still focused
on past or present that's not the way
they wanted to be or making up a future
that's scary
well you're going to be depressed no
matter what unless you take control of
those factors habit number three
identify accurate thinking with dr
daniel ahmed whenever you feel sad or
mad or nervous or out of control write
out what you're thinking
and then
it's five questions but it's is it true
is it absolutely true with a hundred
percent certainty
and that's the one that usually cracks
it
like um
worthless is it absolutely true
now you're getting thoughtful it's like
well i'm a mother
and i'm a sister and i'm a daughter
and
no it's not absolutely true it's
ridiculous
the third question is how do i feel
when i believe i'm worthless
[Music]
dead
withering
sad
lonely
and the fourth question is who would i
be without the thought or how would i
feel if i didn't have the thought
the most common answer to that one is
free
and then
you flip it around
to the opposite it's like
i
am worth something
or i have work
and then
give me an example
or two or three or four
and you have to do that exercise at
least a hundred times
to begin to retrain your
automatic response
i mean i've been teaching people to kill
ants for a long time automatic negative
thoughts but i just found these
five questions they're just so elegant
to just have a dialogue
with yourself i'll never be successful
or i won't have enough money
or my life has no meaning
it's like
well let's put that under a microscope
not positive thinking
accurate
thinking
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four practice
forgiveness with dean graziosi i think
forgiveness is one of those things that
no one would ever consider
as being a success habit nevertheless a
millionaire's success have it what the
hell does forgiveness have to do with it
it's too fufu i i want the i want the
tactical money making stuff right i want
to get to the nitty-gritty but here's
what i know there's only a certain
amount of time in a day there's only a
certain amount of energy in a day and
not even just time and energy the
clarity of creative thinking
compared to the clarity of busy thinking
listen you might have time you're
squeezing it in to think about your
bigger future your bigger business
making more money
but if you
don't have clarity in those thoughts if
your heart isn't open then the universe
god whatever you believe in the
marketing geniuses the marketing
inspiration doesn't funnel down into the
top of your head and come out of your
mouth and without marketing and
creativity then what do you have
without the planning to follow through
without the stamina to get over the
hurdles when she goes sideways what do
you have you have a good idea
everybody's got a good idea you're
listening to me right now not just
because you want some magic money
machine you want the foundation for
wealth and sustainability and success if
i'm if i'm wrong then i apologize maybe
you're looking for the quick hit but how
long does that work even people who hit
the lotto go broke on average right
so what the heck does forgiveness have
to do with success
everything i think forgiveness is one of
the most underutilized uh not just words
but things in our
in our world in in our ability to grow
as a human i want to give you an example
the reason this is on top of my head is
my son uh who just two nights ago when
i'm recording this won the state
championship for their uh 10 year old
division
of baseball which was so awesome so
watch them he did great they did awesome
um but i want to back up my son has been
on the same team since he was four years
old the same coach love this guy he's
one of the greatest guys his wife is
amazing he's amazing loves kids
and they play twice years they pretty
much play all year round he coaches the
all-star team too so he plays spring
ball fall ball and summer
all-star so he's pretty much with this
guy all year round and he's got a son
named dean same name as me and i love
dean i always tease him i said that's my
name i had it first you're bob so when i
get there he's always like no you're bob
but in the last six months
dean's changed
dean has been mean he's been a bully and
especially to my son brody and i think
it's a competitive thing dean is good
brody's better brody's bats first ever
brody's 9 on the 10 11 year old team and
he still bats first probably the best
average on base of anybody on the team
not because he's my son he's just good
he's small but he's good he's a hustler
but last six months dean has been really
tough on brody so i don't want to just
solve this for my son i want him to
figure it out on his own so i keep
saying hey you got to stand up for
yourself i i say hey you know how does
that make you feel
make sure you realize that that's his
opinion that's not who you are like all
the stuff fundamentally out of the book
doing it right trying to empower my son
because i'm not going to always be there
to protect him right
well
the last all-star game as we are
building up to we have the semifinals my
son gets up goes four for four
in the dugout
dean comes up to my son because dean is
sitting there's only one person sitting
my son is smaller than him my son is
younger than him and he's p and his dad
is the coach and he's sitting the bench
he comes up to my son he says you suck
at hitting and you're dumb and my son
said you're dumb for saying that i asked
him exactly what he said and dean
smacked my son in the face
well brody comes out my son's brody
brody comes out of the dugout with a
tear in his eye and his face red i said
what happened he said dean just smacked
me and
listen if you're a parent you know
exactly what happened the the hair on
the back of my neck stood up and i
wanted to go kick
a ten-year-old's ass i just be honest
like i want to go in there and choke him
and say did you lay a hand on my son
i did walk up to him and i said i wanted
to know if it was
i said did you just hit my son and he
didn't say it i said did you just hit my
son
he said yes
i said okay i said go apologize to him
that's all i said i went up and talked
to his mom i was furious i was shaking
on the inside because i know what my
emotions want to do i knew it was right
so why am i telling you this whole story
how's it related to you i promise you it
does
so i went home that night and i was so
mad so upset and but i had the chance to
teach a lesson to brody
and i hated the feeling i had i was mad
at mike who's the greatest guy in the
world greatest dad his son's going
through something somebody's probably
picking on dean and we found out that's
true so
i sat i originally i i emailed mike i
said mike you're a great coach we love
your family but it's unacceptable that
your son put your his hand on my son
it's been six months i've been trying to
get bro to stand up for himself uh
brodie will play the all-star game and
then we're out we're done
mike replied back as a good the good man
he is and said i'm embarrassed as a
coach and i failed as a father i should
have seen this i should have known i
wish i knew sooner and he dug in and he
got it so why am i telling you
because that night i sat with my son and
i didn't like the way it felt to have
anger i didn't like the way it felt to
be mad
and i said buddy the greatest word i
know i wish i knew it sooner is
forgiveness
dean's been a good kid mike's an amazing
dad what if we just forgave them what if
we gave them a second chance what if
if if you want to forgive them i'd like
you to stay on the team but it's totally
up to you he goes no mike's been good to
me i want to stay on the team let's
forgive them
kind of paraphrasing our conversation
so i i email mike we go back to the
practice mike the coach walks up to me
with his head down literally with a tear
in his eye and he said your son and i'm
not saying it's because my boy but he
said yours my son's the sweetest boy
you've ever met in your life sweet voice
he's not aggressive
he might not make it in high school
baseball because he's so not aggressive
he's sweet he's just kind and mike says
to me i'm not just saying this your son
is my favorite kid i've coached in 10
years your son is the reason i coach i
love that kid my son writes the coach
thank you notes that's my son he busts
my chops sometimes but he's amazing
everybody else so
mike comes up and i said mike how about
this
it's it's past it's behind us hopefully
my dean can learn from it we appreciate
everything you've done
and uh we really love you guys thank you
and let's move on from here let's get to
practice and he had a tear in his eye
and he was like i don't understand if if
that was my son and someone did that to
my son i couldn't even look at me i'd
want to fight me he's like
i wish i could let go of things like
that because i probably pulled his hat
off because i'm probably bald because i
worry about all the stuff people have
done to me i said i promise you i'm not
just saying that that's our family we're
done i'm
forgiveness has happened brody brody
goes out i could cry now i could have
tears of mine brody goes out and grabs
dean and says hey let's play catch i
look out these two dean is so sorry that
he's out there playing with brodie
saying good catch brody i'm
so awesome brody i can't wait to watch
you hit today brody you're gonna crush
it today brody my my son was smiling
from ear to ear mike wipes the tears
from his eyes shakes my hand he's like
you're a good man you're a good man i'm
like i'm not a good man just something
simple forgiveness
it's gone for me it's gone for my son he
looked he learned the lesson of a
lifetime my dad couldn't have
forgiveness my dad his father abused him
he took advantage of him his family
abused him so he never forgave anybody
and he lived with anger his whole life
that's probably why i'm the opposite so
how does that relate to you why am i
doing this training on forgiveness
because if you have somebody in your
life who took advantage of you i'm sorry
someone who cheated stole from you lied
to you ruined something ruined a
partnership caused you to go bankrupt
cause you to lose a job it sucks but
guess what if you haven't forgiven them
it's only hurting you because there's so
much only so much time effort and energy
in a day
and if you're using that even with a
fraction of what went wrong why they did
it whose fault is then you don't have
enough to compete in today's world this
is a competitive world you need all your
energy all your juices all your focus
all your enthusiasm focused on where you
want to go not something somebody did to
you you can't undo it so you might as
well forgive that's hard for a lot of
you because some of you are thinking
some pretty horrific things right now
got to forgive them too doesn't mean you
have to forget doesn't mean you have to
be their best friend but forgiveness
will set you free forgiveness will take
you to the next level of life abundance
joy and wealth listen you listen to me
not to get the magic money machine i
love teaching people how to make money
with real estate in other ways but if
you don't go upstream and fix this
it's unsustainable if that's even a word
so that's my message for today forgive
happy number five plan out your goals
with james clear i consider myself to be
someone who's very ambitious and i like
setting big goals in all the things that
you're talking about but i think the key
is you sort of need to oscillate between
these two mindsets and when you're
planning sure think big but when it's
time for progress you need to think
small and scale it down to kind of that
first step um so it doesn't mean that
you can't get to become the type of
person who does 100 push-ups a day it's
just that that's not where we're
starting we're starting with one um
and i think the question you can ask
yourself i mean the first question is
always what am i optimizing for so you
know like people select very different
goals depending on what they're
optimizing for some people are
optimizing for money or relationships or
free time there are many different
things
but that's a very personal choice and
then within that you know what is the
exciting ambitious thing i'm trying to
do
and i think that the question to ask is
who's the type of person that could
achieve that goal who's the type of
person i want to become what is the
identity that i'm trying to reinforce
and so
i like you know like doing one push-up
no it may not transform your body but it
does reinforce the identity of i'm the
type of person who doesn't miss workouts
and
ultimately your habits are a way to
embody your identity it's a way to
reinforce or cast a vote for a certain
type of story
and every action you take is like a vote
for the type of person you want to
become
so doing these small habits you know
yeah they seem like relatively
insignificant at the moment but they're
casting votes for your desired identity
they're building up evidence of that
story and ultimately once you believe
that about yourself man it's a lot
easier to keep going and to make
maintain progress and to eventually
reach that more ambitious outcome habit
number six be courageous with mel
robbins i say that confidence is the
willingness to try
that's all that it is
knowing that you may succeed
or survive
but you'll still try
and
to me all those people that we admire
most
that's what they're doing they have the
ability to tune into
those instincts that are true for them
because the fact is there's only one you
that's it
and you matter because there's only one
you and there's only ever gonna be one
you
and your instincts and your experiences
and your inner wisdom is a gift to the
world and every time that you tune it
out because of the habit of hesitating
or the habit of self-doubt or the habit
of worrying or the habit of overthinking
you are robbing the world of that gift
that you have
to to give to everybody
and you can use this simple stupid silly
tool to train yourself to not only hear
it but also to develop the skill of
courage to act on it and habit number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is get your diet
right with tom billy all right everybody
one of the most important things that
you were ever going to do
in your routine is to get your diet
right
i think that this
outside of having a loving relationship
with my wife i think my diet is the most
important thing that i do
and focusing on
loving relationships
diet and sleep like those are going to
be your top three things so getting your
food right is critically important
because um
this is the easiest way for me to anchor
people around why diet is so important
so first of all you literally are what
you eat literally at a cellular level
you are made of the things you consume
so every cell in your body
is from something that you ate so let
that one sink in
um and then on top of that the largest
nerve in your body known as the vagus
nerve 85 percent of the signals
traveling on that nerve are from your
body to your brain not your brain to
your body so we all have this illusion
that we are this consciousness that
controls everything when in reality the
two work in concert and that the vast
majority of the signaling
is coming from the body so your
microbiome is a huge thing and when you
disregulate your microbiome by eating
things that cause disruption
then
you're now getting all these signals
that your brain is forced to interpret
okay this is one of the read lisa
feldman barrett's book how emotions are
made all of the things that you feel
whether it's happiness sad
anger frustration hopelessness all of
that stuff is your brain interpreting
the signals that it's getting from your
body from the outside world and once you
understand that emotions come from the
body first and then your brain goes hey
the last time that i got these
sensations from all over my body what
did that mean and then your body a sorry
your brain excuse me assigns
a story
to that feeling and now all of a sudden
when you have a dysregulated microbiome
and the microbiome is crying out for
this that or the other all of a sudden
your brain adds a story and i'll give
you an easy one anxiety in my own life i
will tell you that i've struggled
profoundly with anxiety only to at first
think this is entirely in my head and
then finally to realize no no this is
largely how largely
this is again a hypothesis but i have a
gut instinct that this is
anxiety is probably
90 percent your diet
and then
10 percent what you're thinking about
meaning
what you think about is stepping on the
gas but if there's no gas in the gas
tank then you're not going to go
anywhere and by dysregulating your
microbiome through the things that you
eat you put gas in the gas tank of
anxiety and then your thoughts step on
it boom there's plenty of gas and now
you're off to the races so i'm not
saying that your thoughts aren't
important or what's going on in your
life isn't important to triggering
anxiety i'm saying it won't escalate the
way that it does if you
are eating a diet that
keeps your gut flora
nice and happy so that's something i
think a lot about
the number one way to deal with negative
people in your life is through empathy
it's empathy it's not it's not hating
them back it's not spreading negativity
it's not reminding yourself that you're
better than them it's it's empathy
and it's not even just feeling bad for
them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
i default to this human that people are
good
this is a wild idea
people are good humans are good i've
done the who exercise the year one word
exercise helping people find the most
important core value with so many people
and
it's always something positive
i believe that 99.999999999
of people are good there's a tiny tiny
tiny percentage of people who enjoy
killing people and maybe have you know a
few screws loose up here but for the
most part we're good everybody has
dreams everybody has ambitions everybody
wants to serve everybody wants to be in
a better place than where they are right
now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and it didn't work out and
because they're so in pain now they
don't want other people around them to
have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against him is that they actually suck
and they don't want to admit that and
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain
and so they take it out and other people
they take it out on you they take it out
on me they take it out on on the world
they take it out on people right that's
what that's what people do when they're
in a lot of pain think about you
think about your experiences your life
think about when you've been in a lot of
pain
when you've struggled really think about
this the last time that you were
struggling in a lot of pain did you then
show up as your best self in all
situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe
insult somebody did you maybe say
something that you're not proud of that
you later would regret has it has that
ever happened to you so that you're a
bad person so that you're a toxic person
it's not that you're a hater
you were just in a lot of pain
and so the people who are throwing shade
at you are in a lot of pain they're
struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life
and if you know them you can actually
look at their life and if you don't know
them you can assume things about their
life
if if somebody's coming to live in a
negative comment on your youtube video
the fact that that is the highlight of
their day speaks volumes about them
right if the best part of your day is
going to somebody's youtube channel
leaving some nasty comment that gets you
feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in imagine what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning
the natural reaction is to be defensive
like well no i'm not this and how could
you call me that
and
we want the people around to support us
and cheer us on and tell us that we're
doing the right thing so the natural
defense mechanism kicks in where
we say no i'm that's not that's not
right but if you can take a breather you
can take a step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain
what it does is removes the sting from
the words it removes the venom from the
words
it doesn't get you to react
as emotionally it allows you to show up
more as your best self it's it's one of
the most valuable things you can start
to practice this is one of the things
that prevents people from creating
content from posting videos from sharing
their thoughts you've got a big mission
a message your story can change people's
lives you your story your story can
change people's lives it will change
people's lives and we're afraid to do it
because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're going to get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start
sharing to start releasing to start
living your life the life that you want
not somebody else's version of it
people are going to judge you
it doesn't say anything about you
it talks about them their mental state
the pain that they're in the struggle
that they're in the suffering they're in
right now so step number one is have
empathy empathy empathy empathy try to
try to put yourself in their shoes
understand the pain that they're going
through
and and it removes the emotion from what
they're saying and how they're behaving
okay step number two is then is there
any validity in what they're saying
sometimes
there's actually some truth to what
they're saying even even if it's only
one percent truth if it's 99
negativity and one percent truth a lot
of times you know when a customer writes
in maybe they're really upset maybe
maybe they feel cheated maybe they feel
ripped off maybe they feel you didn't do
your job maybe they're maybe they got
cut off in traffic in a really bad mood
today right but maybe they're calling in
to cancel or they get a refund from you
maybe there's some validity in what
they're saying before we just write off
somebody and say you're a negative
person you're toxic i don't want you in
my life maybe there's actually some
truth they presented it very poorly the
packaging was terrible right the
packaging sucked but maybe there's some
validity in the message maybe there's
part truth that you can learn from and i
think this is really important because
if you can only learn from people who
package things really nicely who
sugarcoat everything who put in this
beautiful you know bow to say i love you
and you're amazing and keep doing what
you're doing and i have one little tiny
bit of feedback that maybe you could
learn from like maybe this one little
thing but i love you and you're amazing
like if that's the only way that you can
receive feedback you're never gonna get
the feedback you need to win sometimes
people will rage on you sometimes people
will yell at you sometimes people will
be rude to you sometimes people will
call you names sometimes people will
freak out it's gonna happen
is there any truth right once you can
remove the sting because you have
empathy for them
now you can actually see what they're
saying and see which you can use what
you can digest and what is worth
digesting what you're just going to
discard
because there might be truth
buried somewhere inside of their words
that can make you better that can still
help you that can that can improve your
life and your situation your business
and where you're trying to go so step
number one remove the sting set number
two look for the truth if there is now
there may be some that is just negative
but don't just default to thinking
negative default to thinking maybe
there's a lesson i can learn here and
step number three is then just decide
can you still be around these people or
not this is especially when they're in
your life where they're friends with
their family the people you're seeing
you might have to disconnect for a while
you might have to
because you're not strong enough yet you
might have to
not be around them
because their words hurt too much still
you might have to go and build build
your muscle build your empathy muscle
muscle build your empathy and build your
empathy muscle say that 10 times fast
you might have to go build that muscle
and that means you you spend less time
with them or kick them out of your life
ultimately though
what i see
leaders entrepreneurs you i think you're
a tree and i wrote about this in in my
book built to serve i think you're a
tree what does a tree do a tree breathes
in the carbon dioxide which
too much of for humans is poison we
breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
then they'll spit out oxygen positivity
for the world i see that as part of our
role as leaders and as entrepreneurs is
to eat other people's negativity grow
from it get better from it and then spit
out more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing
will inspire other people to want to
change their life as well whoever is
more confident wins and when you're
around
really negative people
if you are doubting your positivity
they're going to win they're going to
drag you down
but ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy
that you pull them up
that you're more positive you're more
certain in your positivity than they are
certain in their negativity and you pull
them
towards making a better life decision
jesus told his followers all the
miracles that i can do you can do them
but even better than i can and you don't
believe it and that was the whole damn
thing in a nutshell
if you don't believe it you can't do it
and i said well where's belief come from
mind i say you know what have you been
programmed you can't do and i say then
you'll never be able to do it
and this is the problem and i and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know that what you
said was true the evenings just say i
feel amazing i feel amazing if you
repeat that the mind will will all of a
sudden change how you feel that's that's
how it does it okay so i say number one
self-hypnosis number two
after age seven you still learn how to
do new things that become habits like
you didn't learn how to drive a car
until until later then seven but once
you know how to drive a car remember the
first day you got in it was like oh my
god looking out the windows checking the
mirror watching the gauges keeping your
feet on the pedals just correctly you
know looking paying all these attentions
like
and i say today you've been driving for
a while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am i going to do when i get to the
store
you're not even thinking about driving
why it's a habit okay i say well how'd
you get that habit because you're older
than seven how'd you get it i said
repetition that's what makes a habit
practice you want to play an instrument
i'll hand you an instrument yeah you
didn't have any practice then you're not
going to be able to play it and i say oh
practice what is that repetition
that's the second way of subconscious
learns
repeating something over and over and
over again because that's called
habituation making a habit and i love it
the new age today thing is fake it till
you make it like what the hell is that i
say you're not happy yeah most of us
have trouble being happy and i say but
what if every day all day long and you
can remember you say i am happy in spite
of the fact that what the hell is going
on you just say i am happy
i am happy
i am happy i go why what's going on i
say repetition
and there'll be a point where you're
repeated to the degree that the
subconscious which learns by repetition
well put in i am happy i said then
what's the consequence i said what's the
function of the mind take that program
and manifest it now that it's in there i
am happy i wake up one morning guess
what i don't have to say i'm happy it's
automatic i'm already happy all day long
my program said that 95 is coming from
that habituation
you know repetition
of the exact thing you want not future
vision as if you have it now
we'll put it in a program so that's
first seven years hypnosis after seven
years uh repetition habituation is how
you change it uh a sticky note people
put that stuff on a mirror or someplace
and they go oh yeah the little sticky
note and i go that is not repetition
that's a suggestion
a repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving the car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real
okay so the first two things are uh
hypnosis
second thing is repetition
and thirdly the most you know
effective
uh is called energy psychology i go
what's energy
psychology it's called super learning so
what the hell is super learning i go
maybe you've seen somebody read a book
by picking up a book and just moving
their finger down the page just like
that just as fast as that
and guess what
the subconscious mind the super computer
that it is has read every word just by
moving your finger down that has read
every word on that page and a person
using this super learning technique can
go into a bookstore open up a book in
five minutes later by thumbing through
each page turn the page turn the page
turn the page they can read a whole book
in five minutes that's super learning i
say if you can engage that function
you can also use super learning to
create
new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes
it's like
i go absolutely and it's so important
why because uh there's an old phrase
that's really critical it's called
necessity as the mother of invention and
i say what's happening we're facing a
mass extinction due to human behavior
that is compromising the web of life
humans are creating this through our
behavior our culture i say you want to
survive this this whole you know
extinction event
well then you have to create something
different
you have to change behavior there's no
such thing as a mistake everything
happens in divine order i am being
guided to learn and grow here we go
people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth we miss the opportunity to see
what could have been
beneath that discomfort we miss the
opportunity to acknowledge and recognize
that every experience in our life is not
an accident it doesn't happen by
accident it happens in a divine order
and when we live and lead and show up
for our life
grounded in that belief system then we
can face our most difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being and a new perception of our lives
so that's a lot i know that's a lot i
know that when something really bad
happens like what we've been
experiencing recently in the world what
we experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective and a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity
to perceive these situations from the
lens of what can i learn from this how
can i grow from this how can i shift
from this how can i lean towards more
love how can i lean towards more joy how
can i lean into the lesson rather than
the problem the solution rather than
seeking all of the faults and and
looking for all of the problems when i
wake up in the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself usually in
bed what am i most grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful to
be alive i'm grateful you know for my
family i'm grateful to to have
experiences and do you do that eyes
closed yeah i do that eyes closed and
while i
while i think about that i feel it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
i start every day with a great feeling
you have do you visualize some things
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue
i see images of the things that i'm
thinking about and that just takes me
two minutes just two minutes when i wake
up
and then
i go to exercise to take care of my body
how long um usually one hour to an hour
and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise in
my gym
around
half an hour an hour 15 minutes at the
moment
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my
you are known for that yes so i have my
vision board for my my physique and my
body and my health
but then i also have in in my gym
something called an achieved board okay
so after i achieved some of the things
that i achieved past and future no
achieved in the past yes so past you
have the past and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus
to achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals what i
also do is i reinforce most people focus
on what's not working this isn't going
well this didn't work i want to remind
myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror in the gym and i look across and
i say i love you just the way you are
and i said i accept you just the way you
are with all of your skills and passion
and faults and insecurities and doubts
and fears i accept you just the way you
are wow and i smile
and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
wow
and in my meditation sometimes i have
um no thoughts where i'm just one with
the universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain
that i'm in control of my brain if you
practice any new skill for 66 days in a
row through the power of neuroplasticity
which is the brain's ability to adapt
then you are going to reach a point
called automaticity i want you to think
about that term automaticity in other
words after 66 days of practicing the 20
20 20 formula
and joining the 5 a.m club and running
the morning routine you're going to get
to a point where it's automatic you're
going to get to a point where it's
actually easier to get up at 5 00 a.m
than to stay in bed
i also want to offer you a brain tattoo
from the book to consider as you wire in
this morning protocol of billionaires
and highly creative people professional
athletes and industry titans and it's
this all change is hard at first and
it's messy in the middle and it's
beautiful at the end i'm going to repeat
that again for you because it's so
important all change is hard at first if
a new skill or a new routine or a new
habit was easy
then it wouldn't be valuable change
so anything that's valuable
is hard at first you know society says
live an easy life i suggest to you that
whether it's a great morning routine
whether it's building a great business
whether it's releasing your master work
to the world maybe it's a great
relationship maybe it's a great interior
life
it takes real effort it takes the long
game it takes focus it takes hard work
it takes bravery
but the rewards are so much more
glorious than living an easy life okay
so and also remember the things you once
found difficult
you now find easy little kids for
example find walking early on difficult
or learning a new nursery rhyme or
learning how to read or learning how to
build relationships at first there's not
a lot of facility and fluency with those
skills because every skill is difficult
at first until you practice it and then
train until you get to a place where you
master it
and so your morning routine is going to
be challenging at first but with daily
training and practicing the 20 20 20
formula i promise you you're going to
get to a point of mastery
and then the payoffs are extraordinary
your creativity will soar your
productivity will maximize you will
actually attract more prosperity into
your life because the marketplace
rewards true creativity and productivity
you're going to feel so much more
happier in your day you're going to find
that sense of peacefulness so it's
almost like you go through a life with a
greater level of grace and ease you know
the way you start your day determines
the way your day is going to unfold
discipline yourself and so what do you
do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more discipline like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these these
small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's too too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down and what because what are
you going to do you're going to stumble
around and get get what you need you're
going to stumble around and be useful to
other people and it's useful to be
useful to other people you know they
want to work with you then they want to
do things with you they want to have you
around they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome so unless you want that
don't aim for it
and or aim for the opposite because
that's how you get out of it talk to me
about chasing your dreams and this quote
that you have that an aha moment does
not necessarily lead to an aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um
i get choked up when i think about him
an aha moment
i get choked up
because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content
there are people out there that use your
work as a lifeline
and it is humbling and what i am
really present to
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just
how much people are holding themselves
back
and how
much pain people feel
because most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough i
failed so many times i can't go through
that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now
that there is somewhere in your life
that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you
and you are actively arguing against it
you're bringing yourself down you're
beating yourself out like people will
cheer for you and me they won't cheer
for themselves
i'm the same way
and so
this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then uh was promptly
fired after season one it was a huge
failure because we didn't make it to
season two
huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says i have a
dream of being a oscar-winning uh actor
and creating opportunities for other
black and latino men to do the same in
acting and i'm like freaking fantastic
what the [ __ ] are you doing in dallas
right you know the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
and la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not
and he says i have 700 in my bank
account and i'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and i write about it
in this book
where
i am actively arguing for his dream and
he is actively arguing against his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right 700 could get me there
you're right i am only 25. you're right
if i keep thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking about what i want
to be doing i'm not only going to drive
in circles my whole life is going to
spin in circles as i think about what i
want and i don't do [ __ ] about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves what does someone like you
do to meditate how do you meditate
[Music]
when i came to the monastery the
meditation i was taught was mantra
meditation which is chanting on beads so
i chanted mantra
and as i began the process i realized
how
challenging it was
to be present
into the sound of the mantra
and to be totally
in a space in a zone of thoughtlessness
where there's nothing bothering your
mind and you're completely present
and listening to the sound and totally
absorbed
you know in the sound i realized that it
was a massive uphill
task and
i think it comes that the challenge
comes from the fact that we've got so
used to
multitasking
that our mind functions on 20 tracks
so when we're just on the meditation
tracks there are 19 other tracks to deal
with yeah you know you have your
personal life your relationship issues
your professional issues there's so many
things going on and if this is coming
from family
so much going on in the country there's
so much that's occupying our mental
space
when you actually want to get onto the
track of meditation by kind of just
putting all of this in the back seat
it becomes practically
impossible and a lot of people tell me
this when they're trying to meditate
this is what happens to them
and i share my journey with them this is
exactly what happened to me when i
started
it's been 25 years now every single day
without one day's gap one and a half
half hours every day
and i
and i tell them that it's not that it's
not a challenge today
it would be very high-headed to say that
okay i've reached the state of
enlightenment when i said for meditation
everything's kind of there and i'm
totally absorbed very high did i feel to
say that
but i did a few things that i feel can
benefit those who want to
really get into that a deeper state of
meditation
i
i look at meditation in two ways a is
the meditation meditation as in the
practice
and b is everything that we do in our
life as meditation
you know
and i prefer to work more on everything
in my life as a meditation which feeds
into my practice of meditation but do
not neglect the practice do not neglect
the practice for sure
so uh
i'll tell you what i do for instance
one meal a day
i just eat by myself
two meals i take with my friends my some
of my monk friends where we discuss chat
to eat one male is just by myself
the reason being
i want to be present mindful
in the moment to savor the entire
experience of touching feeling
smelling tasting that food i avoid forks
and spoons as much as is possible
because i want to touch
and feel that experience of the food now
the reason i do it is because it just
means no phones no books nobody to talk
to and just being there eating
correct
so what i'm doing is by just eating that
one meal by myself
training my mind
to be in the present
like we are talking now there's three
meetings lined up for me tonight and
there's a restaurant called candy and
greens that breech candy the family is a
very close friend you know so they've
just opened up a new rooftop terrace i
mean getting messages after message
could you come down today evening for
dinner right but it's not in my mind
it's not on my mind nothing outside of a
conversation between you and me right
now is on my mind so why why do i do it
it's because right now i'm training my
mind to be in the present when i used to
be in the bathroom i would sing like a
big thing for me used
because earlier i would sing a lot of
cinema and movie songs and now i sing
some spiritual songs bhajans whatever
and then one day i realized hey wait a
minute this is not right
because neither am i into the singing
nor am i into the experience of bathing
so if i i'm singing i'm missing the
experience of bathing and if i'm bathing
i'm not into my singing so why am i
doing two things at the same time
i stopped singing
just focusing on the experience of the
water
coming down my body and experiencing
that so to me these little things
through the day
matter a lot to me and i think that's a
that's more of meditation to me because
then what i do here feeds into my main
practice of meditation
and what i do here feeds into the little
things as well so it's kind of a loop
one feeding into other showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool
being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up
my body went in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test
you freaking get a perfect grade means
you keep showing up to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success
that means you show up and then you show
up again you show up again you keep
getting better at your game you can't
keep showing up as the old you
you got to show up as the new you
you know mercedes-benz if they just kept
building this vehicle the way they used
to build it
and didn't keep showing up with new
technology
new suspension
new seats
new choices new colors
you know the matte black
the red guts
new navigation system you got to have a
new game every day baby you got to have
a new game every day and the follow up
you got to have
you got to have new follow-up you can't
have a new i can't can't do the same
thing you did that didn't work yesterday
we're doing a 10x growth conference i'm
doing a 10x this year i'm not doing the
same 10x i did last year it's a new year
new time new audience
new speakers
now that being said when i show up in
the 10x growth conference in las vegas
on 2 20 20 20
i just spent six hours this morning
working out what we're doing
okay
i'm not going to show up the way i did
last year jumping out of a damn plane
i'm going to show up in a different way
okay in a different way in a unique way
but i am not going to abandon the things
that work for the audience and for
myself
so you got to find this really really
cool mixture between
repeating what works
and showing up as a new person all the
time
if you're reading a book
okay you listening to music
going to an event uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in an event
it's the 700th time you did that
presentation you got to show up new
again
johnny comes to work with his camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterdays
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [ __ ] but it's got
to be fresh
i need some fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either so you gotta keep showing up
showing up means you're looking for
deeper levels to show up to pay
attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why did
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference but it's
showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up the key thing
super producers do
the best of the best
they get up early
so
here's what i wanted to share with you i
wanted to literally deconstruct the 5
a.m club concept which is just you get
up at 5 o'clock you give yourself one
hour in the greatness guide i call it
the holy hour which you're not in the
world you're not checking your
notifications you're not anywhere near
technology you're not watching the news
you're not chit chatting you're not
daydreaming you are literally running a
one hour period of practice to set up
your mindset your heart set your health
set your soul set the four interior
empires that i teach at personal mastery
academy
so that by six o'clock
you feel fundamentally different now you
might be saying robin
what
5 a.m
well if you're feeling that any good
idea is going to disrupt you any new
idea will shake you up a little bit and
so if you're feeling i couldn't do that
if your mind is full of chatter on
excuses if you say you know robin i
can't win the battle of bed i can't put
mind over mattress my father couldn't
get up early mum couldn't get up early
grandpa used to sleep in i just don't
have the genetics to allow me to get up
early
yes you do we know from the research of
university college london
that it takes 66 days to wire in
neurobiologically
a new habit 66 days
and as you know from my brain tattoo
that is very well known all change is
hard at first if it wasn't hard at first
to get up early it wouldn't be valuable
change and it's messy in the middle and
it's beautiful at the end
so if you want to get up early if you
want to have a gargantuan competitive
advantage if you want to have a massive
opportunity because most people
they might have great products they
might
have a great mindset they might be great
entrepreneurs or great performers they
might be working at a great company they
might have a corporate culture that is
fantastic
but most people on the planet will never
get up at 5am and that's why it is a
gargantuan competitive advantage for you
the rest of the world is pretty much
sleeping those of us who love getting up
at five o'clock we know it's the
quietest time of the day
imagine this having one hour from five
to six
just for yourself
imagine one hour
where there's such a stillness in the
air
where you can actually breathe and think
and be
and the spartan warriors say it so well
and this if you're interested in this
concept
the book is that that i've written is
the 5 a.m club and one of the lines i
use comes from the spartan warrior credo
and the spartans those great warriors
here's what they used to say
the one who
sweats more in training
bleeds less
in war
and so
five to six your holy hour is simply
it's a training practice it's a training
ground like the great warriors so that
when you go out in the world you bleed a
lot less you have a lot more focus a lot
more energy you're focused on your
priorities and your values versus
society's priorities and their values
and you know what i want to say to you
some days i get up at 4 45 to start my 5
a.m protocol
and i feel exhausted and i don't want to
do it
and i say
why have i been teaching this 5am club
concept for so many years to the leaders
i work with and the people who come to
the titan summit you know and people
like richard branson have been on my
stage and steve wozniak the co-founder
of apple and shaquille o'neal was in the
room at the titan summit a number of
years ago and why do i teach this and
why do i teach the protocol
well here's the key
not only will it fundamentally change
the way your days play out but the way
you feel at six is very different from
the way you feel when you first wake up
so
give yourself 66 days please understand
that getting up early is a gargantuan
competitive advantage and it will be the
single best thing or certainly one of
the single best daily habits that you
could possibly install in your life if
you're seriously interested in legendary
leadership being a world builder and a
history maker
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to move your life forward with some
incredible jordan peterson motivation
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i believe that
you should struggle uphill towards the
city of god on your crutches you're full
of biological potential that won't be
realized unless you move yourself around
in the world